I never fear uncle Joey's here and he's
back in the stand me smoking this Master
Kush transmission fluid [__]
grandpa's cough medicine were off and
running
tonight [__] Minneapolis tomorrow
night howson comedy oh [__] give me the
loop give me the loot oh [__]
give me the look give it a look are you
[__] kidding me war off and running
tonight brother Danny Brown called from
the airport I miss him already
that's a bad black [__] I don't
even make [__] like that no
more so I'm very happy you guys turned
me on to him I got turned on to his
music I love you [__] beside
that that's it is what we're doing
tonight little reefer we got my man
Kevin couch coming in from [__] care
me and Kevin go back [__] 15 years he
produced my first CD live at the three
of clubs and he's one of us yeah I'm
saying so strap a pair and get your [__]
together [__] cuz that's how we do it
in the stand
give it a look give it a loop you want a
pipe or a bomb how do you want to do
this [__] let's do the bomb
give me the loop give me the loop that's
a week we come right in with the bum
understand me there's no [__] drama
see it there's no warmups there's no
jumping jacks
[Music]
[Laughter]
little tray here next time you go eat
Chinese food they give you a tray take
it to go just leave the check don't like
what I'm to the tray uncle Joey I work
for the funk I live for the [__] I live
for the [__] oh [__] [__] we're going
deep in the murky waters I don't know
[Music]
just go straight walk in the office I
live for the [__] I live for the [__]
listen you're not gonna have a good time
it's not gonna work out for you for
years I walked around having a good time
don't work out
[Music]
a little biggie the first down 1995 poor
it completely [__] apart that's how
[__] happens
couple years later he's dead what are
you gonna do I miss him this good music
man yeah I was a Comley store when they
shot him hey shadow found Wilshire
Boulevard but what are you know we can't
cry over spilt milk or you can do is
smoke more reefer yeah I'm saying this
is the King Louie this is direct from
[__] oh [__] this smells like my
fungi toenail that means it's gonna be
good my fungi toenails going away
finally and the baking soda the CBD
Lyndsey dick to it you gotta put baking
soda on it and it takes some [__]
pills my kidneys hurt
[Music]
I'm proud to have Kevin couch on this
[__] is my little brother for
many moons ago well nobody even knew
what a podcast was National Lampoon
podcast
[Music]
look a list of my story but I found that
so I get the line I got that oh [__] oh
[Music]
[__] is this see hey Jemaine and why
anybody for barley
[Music]
oh all the guns was for
that's my film operetta here we go and
you thought it was like be a home
Wednesday night
I'm gonna watch scandal so [__] yourself
you watched uncle Joey
Kevin couch and his [__] trusted
bodyguard Lisa at you what yes she don't
[__] you're the mad wisdom he's dying
over or you got just given one bong
I don't know what dick is I'm here with
you [__] while I'm doing gar me
what [__] TV you talking
[Music]
we go yeah
you ready [__]
[__] the King Louie coming
through King Louie that's the
[__] to kill Princess Diana this
is the [__] that killed Princess Diana
she took a bong of this and her army
crashed the car
whatever is [__] them I'm not good
with dates and [__] like that but anyway
we're gonna do one more bond and then
when I get this party started
youtube.com slash c lu / Joey Diaz /
churches some [__] I don't [__] know
look outside your window I'll be out
there with two flags and [__] send your
coats
[Music]
he's ready
oh [__] and we also got Lee's favorite
blue [__] cookies oh we got
nothing but Reapers nice this is the
house of Reaper look at this [__] is the
house from all over the Russians the
Germans the Jews I got weed
international is these buds
[Music]
oh yeah yeah a long tube not a long
tubes a duck I'm saying thank God that
24k is over there was one day I just sat
down my little tricycle
beeping and no pod you know I'm saying
youtube.com slash c / church Joey Diaz
all right I'll see you [__] in
10 minutes get it together remember give
it a loop give me the loop papa bear